الى وزاره الداخليه وقوات الامن وكذلك
وزاره الخارجيه
وتعقمها
الذي دعمنا في هذه الامر وكذلك نشكر
البريد التركي
ومؤسسه المواصلات التركيه
وكافه رؤساء البلديات
والعاملين في البلديات خلال الحمله
الانتخابيه وكل من كان سندا ومتعاونا لنا
خلال
اجراء الانتخابات من الموظفين الحكوميين
وكلهم يستحقون كل الشكر وانا اشكرهم
بجزيل الشكر والان قد تم فتح جميع
الصناديق
ونجد انه قد كانت نسبه المشاركه اثنين ذات
90% اما
بالنسبه المشاركه في الخارج
52.99 بالمئه بالخارج
وانه هناك خمسه وستين الف
وستميه من البيانات التي دخلت مؤخرا وحسب
النتائج غير المؤكده ان الرئيس اردوغان
حصل على
49.51 بالمئه وكمل
44.88
0.5
5.7 واما ايضا محرم انجاز صفر فاصل 44
و35
الصوت
نجد الذي دخل الان تم تجريبه وقد كان له
اردوغان وبالتالين راى بانها نسبه اردوغان
قد وصل الى
49,54 وايضا
في حال ايضا حسبان صوت انه نسبه الاصوات
44.45 بالمئه النتيجه وحسب القانون ايضا
نجد بان لا احد من المرشحين قد استطاع ان
يبلغ النصاب المحدد
للفوز وبالتالي 22 مايو يوم الاحد سيتم
اجراء الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات وذلك
بقرار من الهيئه العليا للانتخابات وانا
اتمنى بان ويكون هذا القرار جانبا الخيرات
لبلدنا وللاحزاب السياسيه ايضا واود ان
ازودكم ببعض المعلومات المختصره عن الجوله
الثانيه من الانتخابات بدايه
انهم
بعد الاعلان عنه قائمه المرشحين مؤقته
وفقا للماده القانونيه المعنيه ايضا
وانه يتم تحديد موعد
الجوله الثانيه للانتخابات ولجنه والهيئه
العليا الانتخابات اتخذت قرارا في ذلك
وبالتاليس
يتسابقوا نعم
المتنافسان الاولان في الجوله
الثانيه وفي حاله انسحاب احد
نعم ايضا احد المرشحين سيتم التقديمي في
التاريخ ايضا وانه
الورقه الانتخابيه
الترتيب لا يختلف فيها وبالتالي في عدم
فقط قيل انه اذا ما تم انسحاب احد
المتنافسين يمكن من القائمه الانتخائيه
وبالتالي سنرى في الورق الانتخابيه السيد
اردوغان في الدرجه الرتبه الاولى المرتبه
الاولى وكلسترول في المرتبه الثانيه ايضا
هو بالتالي يمكن البدء
بحمل الانتخابيه مره اخرى
بدايه من
الاعلان ويمكن
نعم اما التاريخ القرار النهائي
للاعتراضات ثمانيه عشره
المصادف يوم الخميس
واما يوم الجمعه والمصادف لتسعه عشر مايو
ستكون النتائج النهائيه معلنه وبعد
الاعلان عن النتائج الرسميه فان سيبدا
التصويت
والى تاريخ 24 مايو
واما خارج هذا ما سيبدا بالخارج وفي داخل
يوم 28
مايو المصادف ليوم الاحد
وكذلك كما هو الشان في الجوله الاولى
سيتم اقتراح
لخطابات المتنافسين في التلفاز والاذاعه و
28 مايو
اتمنى ان تكون الجوله الثانيه وسيله خير
لنا هذه الجوله الثانيه التي ستجرى في 28
مايو وهذا